These are the four most powerful writing
frameworks that I've ever come across. As an
English professor and writing coach, I've spent
my career analyzing the world's best writers,
and what I'm going to give to you
here are four writing patterns that,
once you see them, you're going
to start spotting them everywhere.
So today, I want to offer to you a
writing framework that'll help you
keep your readers focused. A framework
that'll give your writing momentum.
A framework that'll help you break down
complex ideas into simpler units. And a
framework that'll help you weave together
multiple strands into a single idea.
Now, these frameworks are not just style tips
or my own list of personal preferences. They're
the cognitive patterns that readers use
to interpret your text. And by analyzing
the writing patterns from the
perspective of reader psychology,
it's going to help you write more clearly
and, more importantly, more valuably.
So to start, let's take a look at the
same passage written two different ways,
because this is going to let you in on the
principle that underlies all four patterns.
The original passage is taken from Mihaly
Csikszentmihalyi. Csikszentmihalyi — he's
the guy who wrote about flow. But before I get
to his original passage from the book *Flow*,
what I'd like to do is look at the same passage
written differently, because it's the difference
between them that's going to help you see
this principle that we're talking about.
So my edit, the bad version, says:
> Things that happen are not what produces
happiness. Good fortune and random chance
don't result in it either. Money can't
buy it and power can't command it.
Outside events do not determine it. Our
interpretation of those events does.
Preparation, cultivation, and private defense
by each person are what this condition requires.
Now, if I asked you what
was wrong with that passage,
it might be hard to say. I mean, there's no
grammar mistakes in it. It has all the pieces
that we need to understand what he's talking
about, but something seems a little bit off.
So let's contrast that with the original
from Csikszentmihalyi's book, which says:
> Happiness is not something that happens. It is
not the result of good fortune or random chance.
It is not something that money can buy or power
command. It does not depend on outside events,
but rather on how we interpret them. Happiness,
in fact, is a condition that must be prepared for,
cultivated, and defended privately by each person.
Now, speaking of flow, I think you'd agree
that that latter passage was a lot easier
to understand. And you might have spotted
the difference, but in case you haven't,
the key difference between these two passages is
that in the one that's difficult to understand,
we find all these different elements organized in
the topic position. At the start of the sentence,
we see *things that happen*, *good fortune*,
*money*, *outside events*, *preparation*.
And so if you were to look at just these
elements in the topic position without
reading the rest of the passage, could
you predict what this passage is about?
Well, let's contrast that with the topics that we
find in Csikszentmihalyi's version. We see in the
topic position of these clauses: *happiness*,
*happiness*, *happiness*, *happiness*,
*happiness*. So if you were to zoom out and just
say, what is this passage about — the one in which
all these sentences are joining together — what's
it about? It's really easy to say: happiness.
And so the difference between the passage
that's difficult to read and easy to read
has nothing to do with grammar and
everything to do with organization.
The information is organized so that old,
familiar information is in the topic position,
and then all the new information comes at the
end of the sentence in what's called the comment.
And an easy way to think about this topic and
comment is to think that the topic of a clause
is kind of like a doorstep, and then the comment
is the room that the reader is going to walk into.
And so with that image in mind, let me tell
you about the first writing framework. This
is the perfect framework to use whenever
you want to elaborate on a single topic,
to add more and more details to it. And in fact,
it's the pattern that Csikszentmihalyi
used in the passage that we just looked at.
So returning to that passage,
we see the first sentence says,
"Happiness is not something that happens." And
so in the topic position of this first sentence,
we have the word *happiness*. And then we see all
these pronouns and the word *happiness* repeated,
recurring through every successive clause. All
the new, complex information is developed in the
comment position, and all the topics are coherent.
They're all linking back to the same element.
And so if you hold on to that image
of the topic being like a doorstep,
then this first pattern is kind of like
you're having the reader stand there
and look in the different cardinal
directions. There are multiple ideas
being developed and attached to this
single element that keeps in focus.
So, as you see, this pattern is what allows us
to stay anchored on one topic while developing
multiple ideas about it. And it's perfect
for whenever you are describing something,
or characterizing something, or just developing
a multifaceted idea. You don't want the reader
to get lost in all the details, and so this
pattern allows you to keep the reader anchored
on the one element that you want them to focus
on. And from that vantage point, they'll be able
to integrate all these ideas that you develop,
as we see here in the passage about happiness.
Now, this pattern is really handy,
but you should be warned that it can
create a kind of stagnant feeling in the
passage. So you really want to reserve it
for moments whenever you really need
to elaborate on something and unpack
multiple ideas about a single entity. But beware
that it is going to make your reader feel stuck,
because they're standing on the doorstep and
they're looking in these different directions.
But of course, you don't always want the
reader to be standing still. Sometimes
you want to give them some movement, and that's
what the next framework is for. And by the way,
if you want to take a closer look at these
frameworks, then you can get my free visual guide
to expert writing down below the like button.
It contains not only these four frameworks,
but actually four pages of frameworks and
patterns that I've used to help writers
make their writing more clear and more valuable.
Totally free. Link is down below the like button.
So what is this second framework, and how can you
use it to give your writing a feeling of momentum?
Well, in the last section, we talked about
the framework being as though you have the
reader stood on a doorstep and then turning
them into different cardinal directions.
But with this framework, you want to imagine that
from the doorstep, the reader steps into a room,
and then from that room, they're now standing
in a new room. They have a new vantage point,
and the next clause brings them into the next
room. Right? It's one step after the other,
and they're successive steps, right? These
aren't teleportations. We're not jerking
the reader around the house from one room
to another. Everything is linking one into
the other. And in fact, that's what the
pattern is called: the linking pattern.
So let me give you an example of how
this works. This comes from James Gleick,
in his excellent book *Chaos: Making
a New Science*. So the passage says:
> Outside his window, Lorenz
could watch real weather,
the early morning fog creeping along the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology campus
or the low clouds slipping over
the roofs from the Atlantic.
Fog and clouds never arose in the model running
on his computer. The machine, a Royal McBee,
was a thicket of wiring and vacuum tubes that
occupied an ungainly portion of Lorenz's office.
And so what we see with this framework is that
each topic is linking back not to the original
topic, but to the end of the previous clause.
That is, it's picking up the element
that's in the comment and using that as
the next starting point, and that's what
gives it this sense of forward momentum.
So we see the first topic is "outside
his window" — Lorenz would be
the first topic — and at the end we have two
elements in the comment position. We have *fog*
and we have *clouds*. Those are the
elements that are in the comment position,
and then those elements get repeated. They're
linked back in the next topic, right? We see
"fog and clouds." What about them? "They never
arose in the model running on his computer."
And then *computer* becomes the topic of the next
clause: "The machine, a Royal McBee, was a thicket
of wiring." And notice that at the end of this
clause, we are now ending back where we began.
Now, that's not absolutely necessary, but it's
a nice touch, and I'm going to give you another
example in a moment to show what can happen when
you don't kind of close this loop. But just for
the moment, notice what's happening and how this
gives the passage this kind of forward motion.
This kind of a pattern is excellent for whenever
you want the reader to be moving through space. So
that could be in a passage where you're describing
travel, but it's also excellent — you know, I work
in academia, and so this is a really good pattern
for the method section of a scientific report.
But it's really useful for anything that involves
process, you know, one step after another. If you
need to show any causal chain, this is the
kind of framework that you'd want to use.
But a moment ago, I mentioned that,
you know, this is a nice touch,
the way Lorenz — the comment of this passage
— links back up to the topic where we began.
That's a nice touch, because watch what happens
if we don't have that kind of a closed loop.
Here's the same pattern. It's
exactly the same linking pattern,
but what you're going to notice is that it kind of
falls apart. And I wonder if you can see why. Now,
this passage is not from professional prose. It's
just something I whipped up to prove a point,
but see if you can spot where it
goes off the rails. So it says:
> Soon, Portland will be the coffee roasting hub
of the nation. The aroma of roasting beans fills
the streets, and gleaming espresso machines line
the counters. The machines remind me of my dad's
old typewriter, covered with keys I would press
randomly. His typewriter always jammed on me.
That's why I avoided it. I prefer to write
with blue pen on yellow legal pads. This
preference has been the topic of heated debates
between me and my creative writing professor.
All right. Now, this is exactly the same pattern.
We have the topic picking up the comment of the
previous clause. But the problem is that when
you zoom out and you look at these topics,
just as we did at the start here — when you
just analyze the topics, can you tell me what
this passage is about? Right. Let's take a closer
look. All right. This passage is about *Portland*,
*coffee beans*, *espresso machines*, *typewriter*,
*that*, *I*, *preference*, *creative
writing professor*. Like, it's hard to see.
One way to think about it is to say it's
hard to picture these elements on the same
stage. If these are all characters in a
play, then you might ask yourself, like,
what are they doing together, right?
So what is this passage about?
And that's what happens. If you start linking all
these clauses together, you get a nice experience
of flow or momentum, but as a writer, you kind
of need to keep them on track. In other words,
you need to keep everything coherent. So it
works in this passage about Lorenz because
the author is kind of taking us on a guided
tour of his office. We start looking at Lorenz,
and then we kind of zoom out a little bit
and look at the context of the environment.
We're kind of floating around in space,
and then we're brought back to Lorenz.
Now, again, I think there are
different ways that you can
use this. I don't think you necessarily
always need to loop back where you began,
but you do need to be careful about the
way that you use this pattern, because
it's kind of like railroad tracks, and you
don't want it to take you too far off course.
Now, for this third writing framework, you
might notice that it actually breaks a rule.
So far we've been talking about repetition, and
sometimes that repetition happens just through
repeating the word or using pronouns. And in other
cases we have synonyms being used. So for example,
"the machine," right, and "the Royal McBee"
replacing "the machine," right — "his
computer." So we can use synonyms, or
pronouns, or just straight repetition.
But for this third writing framework,
you're actually going to notice that it
breaks that rule entirely. We don't repeat
the same element in the topic positions,
but it still works. So let me read it for
you and see if you can see how this one
works. This model passage, by the way,
comes from Steven Pinker, and it says:
> When neuroscientists look directly at
the brain, using a variety of techniques,
they can actually see language
in action in the left hemisphere.
The anatomy of the normal brain, its bulges
and creases, is slightly asymmetrical.
In some of the regions associated with language,
the differences are large enough to be seen
with the naked eye. Aphasics' brains almost
always show lesions in the left hemisphere.
Right? So if we examine the topics
of all of these successive clauses,
we find that there is no repetition. These are
all different elements, but somehow they do
seem to work together. I don't know about you,
but I found that passage pretty easy to read.
And so what's the difference between this
passage and the one that we just looked at
about the Portland coffee beans? Right?
This one about the Portland coffee beans
seems pretty incoherent, yet this one
from Steven Pinker works. Why is that?
Well, it's a little bit like walking into a
cathedral, right? If you walk into a cathedral,
you're not going to be very surprised to find
inside the nave, the crypt, and the pulpit.
In other words, once the whole is on stage,
you're not going to be surprised to see its parts.
And that's what's happening here. We see the whole
element being introduced in the comment position
— that being the left hemisphere, which is the
language center of the brain — and then different
aspects of that one element are introduced in all
the successive comments. We have "the anatomy of
the normal brain" being developed in one comment.
In the next clause we have "in some of the regions
associated with language," right, over here.
And then third we have "aphasics' brains."
So although these are different topics,
they're different elements — right,
the topics are indexing different things
— those three things are subsumed below
the one topic, the kind of general category
that's introduced in the comment position.
And this is an excellent pattern for whenever
you're providing a taxonomy, or just a kind
of — you're categorizing something, or you're just
breaking down one element into its various parts.
Although the parts are going to be
scattered and they're not going to be
renaming the same topic, whenever you provide
this kind of high-level introduction of the
category on top of it, almost like an umbrella,
then it lends coherence to the whole passage.
But for contrast, I think it's also helpful to
look at how this pattern can go wrong. So what I'd
like to do now is just read you another passage
with something missing, and you can try to see if
you can tell what goes wrong with it. And so this
passage, which follows the same pattern, says:
> After gathering the smallest and most colorful
leaves from the maples and oaks in our backyard,
we place the leaves between
sheets of blotter paper,
which we then cover with a large
heavy book. In just a day or two,
the leaves are ready to be mounted on cards.
We use plain index cards folded in half.
Using clear adhesive paper, we put one leaf on
each card, leaving room for the guest's name.
Now, the first question would be: how
was that? Was that easy to read? Well,
I think we'd all agree no. There's
something wrong with that passage.
(Mosquito attack.)
And so what is it that's gone
wrong with this passage? Well,
the thing that it's missing — and the reason
why it seems so kind of incomprehensible or
disjointed — is that it's missing this index
clause, right? If you're going to have a passage
which names these varying topics, you need to be
specific in naming the category, or the kind of
super-theme, that joins them all together.
If that theme is only implied — right,
if you don't name it specifically where
readers are expecting to find it — then
they're going to find all the successive
clauses in this passage totally incoherent.
And so if we were to introduce in the
index position a clause that kind of
hangs over them all as an umbrella,
suddenly they snap into place. Watch:
> Each Thanksgiving we make place cards decorated
with pressed autumn leaves. After gathering the
smallest and most colorful leaves from the
maples and oaks in our backyard, we place the
leaves between sheets of blotter paper, which
we then cover with a large heavy book. In just
a day or two, the leaves are ready to be mounted
on cards. We use plain index cards folded in half.
Using clear adhesive paper, we put one leaf on
each card, leaving room for the guest's name.
Ah, like, see, they all snap
into place. So that tells you
the importance of having a kind of
unifying category on top of it all.
Now, this last writing framework is excellent
for whenever you need to weave together
multiple strands into a single cohesive thread.
And so, keeping with the metaphor that we've
been developing here, if the topic is like the
doorstep where a reader arrives before we present
them with something new, then the comment of this
last pattern is a little bit like a tour guide
approaching the reader and saying, "We're going to
go to this room, that room, and this other room."
In other words, it's giving them a preview of
the major turns that they're about to take.
And so let's watch this in action, and
then I'll show you the framework and how
to use it. This example passage comes from
Jonathan Haidt. He's an excellent writer,
and this passage occurs in his book
*The Righteous Mind*. And so it says:
> In their theory of morality, Shweder et al.
found three major clusters of moral themes,
which they called the ethics of
autonomy, community, and divinity.
The ethic of autonomy is based on the
idea that people are first and foremost
autonomous individuals with wants, needs, and
preferences. The ethic of community is based
on the idea that people are first and foremost
members of larger entities such as families,
teams, armies, companies, tribes, and nations.
The ethic of divinity is based on the idea that
people are first and foremost temporary vessels
within which a divine soul has been implanted.
And so what you might have spotted already is
that the comment of this first index clause
sets up A, B, and C. And then
those elements that occur at the
end of the comment each get picked up in
successive clauses. A gets developed here,
B gets developed here, and C gets developed
here. So that's why it's called a theme
preview. It's giving the reader a heads-up of
the three major turns that we're about to take.
But a failure to watch out for with this passage
is the use of synonyms. The reason this all snaps
together is because these words echo the key
terms that were put out in the comment position
of the first clause. If we were to use a
synonym here — *community*, such as, like,
*groups* — well, it wouldn't have the same
cohesive structure as using the same term,
or a very close, not synonym, but
analog, like *community* and *communal*,
or *autonomy* and *autonomous*. Those are fine,
because they link back to the same key terms.
But if you try to use synonyms here, you're really
kind of taxing the reader's mental framework,
because they have to keep track of these three
elements. And if you can help them keep track
of that by repeating the same terms, then they
can snap the information into this structure.
Now, we've been looking at these passages in the
context of paragraphs, but keep in mind that these
can occur at different levels of resolution, and
you can even mix and match them. So for example,
if you can expand this pattern out to an entire
section, right, you can imagine the introduction
of a section announcing three major themes, and
then several paragraphs being given to element A,
and several paragraphs being given to element
B, and so on and so forth, linking back with,
you know, major signposts like *first*,
*second*, *third* to help the reader keep track.
Then within this macro structure,
you can introduce other patterns,
such as the linking pattern, right? You
can go old to new, right? New information
gets picked up in the old information,
in that kind of stepped linking pattern,
in whatever way you can. So try to expand
this out into different levels of resolution.
And when you're done, you need to watch
this video next, because it's going to
give you five more patterns that I see not
only at the level of sentence organization,
but across the entire essay.
So be sure to go check it out.